We live in a world where the idea of love
is fed by a "Happily Ever After".
Our perception of what should and should not
be is completely skewed by what we have learned
in media.
The typical pattern of intense passion and
emotions, a conflict that makes us fight for
that God forsaken love and then the resolution
of being together forever.
We see any romantic or sexual interests outside
of that relationship as immoral and that we
must constrain ourselves for this one love
for the rest of our lives.
But is there such a thing as your one and
only love?
Is it not possible to love more than one soul?
This question has resulted in cheating, divorce,
resentment, conflicts and a lot of lying.
Is monogamy the only way to be in a loving
relationship?
More and more people are finding healthy relationships
inside consensual, non-monogamous relationships.
In actuality, the cultures that only accept
monogamous relationships are in the minority
worldwide.
According to a paper in the journal of evolutionary
biology, 83% of societies allow polygamy.
At Psych2Go, we're bringing you the "8 signs
polyamory may be right for you".
The first sign is that you have always felt
limited and confined in conventional relationships.
It's not the person you're with that's making
you feel confined, it's the situation.
Have you ever felt like you're no longer acting
as an individual but always thinking about
being faithful to your partner and you can't
help but think; does this come from a place
of love, freedom and security or does it come
from a place of ownership, jealousy and fear?
Sign number two is that you learn so much
about yourself through others.
Relationships are fun, yes, but they're also
incredible opportunities to learn and explore
different aspects of yourself.
Each person is a universe and both negative
and positive experiences that we venture in
with them are a journey to learning and growing
individually as a person.
If you are limited to only one relationship,
there may be aspects of yourself you are neglecting.
Sign number three is that you are the kind
of person who feels energized by other people.
Does diving into experience with people outside
of your primary relationship, nurture, energize
and refresh you?
Do you feel energized and refreshed after
you have an innocent yet perhaps a little
flirtatious coffee with someone from the opposite
sex whilst in a relationship?
This does not have to imply any physical engagement;
an innocent lunch date is enough.
In a polyamorous relationship, you are free
to flirt, have fun and share your experiences
with other people in any way you desire.
Sign four is that you like to constantly challenge
yourself in order to grow.
The most common reason for people rejecting
an open relationship is jealousy.
They would rather not deal with the intensity
of jealous feelings they would get with the
very imagination of their partner engaging
with someone else.
But what if polyamory will teach you to be
less jealous and to love with complete freedom,
would this not be like taking an entire weight
off of your shoulders?
This experience, while still being a very
difficult one will teach you to love someone.
Fear, jealousy and possession are not things
that come from a place of love.
Consider it a love boot camp.
Sign number five is that communication and
honesty are very important things for you.
You can't stand lying about anything and let's
be honest, most people feel safer not admitting
to their partners that they may be interested
in or attracted to someone else.
They may also not feel safe about telling
their partner about certain friendships for
fear of jealousy.
You are the kind of person who would rather
be open about these difficult topics and feel
safe in approaching them with your partner.
You think it's best and healthier to tackle
the situation and finding a compromise that
makes you both happy.
If there is something forbidden to us, we
will only want it more.
If we feel free to be with somebody else,
then the initial excitement of that forbidden
fruit is gone.
Sign number six is that you don't like living
life by society's rules and tend to question
everything.
You are not one to follow social constructs
of what should and should not be.
You often find yourself questioning these
in-positions made on us.
Polyamory is instantly rejected by society
and almost seen as a threat to normal relationships
and normal family life.
However, you prefer to live and experience
for yourself before deciding your opinion
on something as opposed to following everybody
else like a sheep.
Sign number seven is that you trust your love
and connection with this person more than
anything.
You don't think that seeing someone else could
possibly take away from your love and devotion
to your partner.
If anything, it might even strengthen your
appreciation for them.
If the connection you have is authentic, then
it is really hard for that to just go away
with the introduction of someone new.
Sometimes we just enjoy someone new in our
lives but that does not mean we want them
to ever replace our partner.
And finally, sign number eight is that you
are aware that we can love more than one person
and feel attracted to more than one person.
If we learn to accept that one person cannot
fulfill every desire that we have, then we
will immediately resent our partner less and
appreciate them more.
If we decide to allow ourselves and our partners
to fulfill things we can't through someone
else, we are making them happy and that my
friend is love.
Thank you for watching this video and hopefully
these signs helped you see if you'd potentially
be open for a polyamorous relationship or
if you're more happy in a monogamous one.
Let us know if any of these signs relate to
you in the comments and any videos you might
like to see next.